salut alors je sais on a en août et
j'avais dit il y aura pas de vidéo en
août mais il s'est passé quelque chose
qui mérite que je sois si une vidéo
nous avons franchi le cap des 600 mille
personnes qui suivent la chaîne se dire
qu'il ya un an tout pile quasiment jour
pour jour on était à peine 60 milles et
là on est six cent mille merci bravo
vous êtes comme ça alors je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais pour les deux
cent mille abonnés j'avais créé un truc
pour que vous ayez tous un cadeau mais
vraiment tous des 200 milles un cadeau
physique vous aviez été 17000 a envoyé
un courrier pour le recevoir
alors pour les 600000 je vous propose
quelque chose dans le style mais plus
facilement accessibles c'est à dire
j'aime créer quelque chose comme vous
avez dû voir dans le titre qui va être
accessibles aux six cent mille personnes
si vous voulez c'est un cadeau alors il
s'agit d'un tour de magie que vous
pouvez faire passer pour du mentalisme
pourquoi j'ai pris cette option là pour
vous offrir quelque chose peut écouter
c'est très simple monsieur vous le dire
tout de suite c'est parce que là je
voulais vous offrir quelque chose d'un
rat table ce terrain qui a pas besoin
d'un entraînement il n'y a pas d'erreur
possible ça fonctionnera à tous les
coups et avant de vous présenter sachez
que donc ça va être accessible d'une
manière virtuelle pour vous comme ça
tout le monde peut la voir mais j'ai
aussi créé une version collector qui se
trouvent dans cette petite enveloppe
juste ici le thème que vous allez
utiliser pour en parler à vos
spectateurs ou à vos amis quand vous
l'avez leur faire les faits ça va être
le thème de la fréquence des longueurs
d'onde des couleurs oui je parle du
mékong league et ainsi que la fréquence
des neurones qu'on peut mesurer dans le
cerveau lorsqu ils identifient une forme
simple avec sa deux effets possibles
n'ont pas non pas trois mais deux adam
l'ain où vous allez prédire une
fréquence il va être librement choisi et
de manière aléatoire par un spectateur
et l'autre vous allez faire un calcul
mental ultra rapide mais plus rapide
tumeur dans leur enveloppe que vous
allez recevoir vous explique à la fin
comment vous allez faire pour la
recevoir vous allez trouver ses cinq
petits cartons comme ce site quand je
vous dis que c'est du collector c'est
une impression de qualité sur un papier
avec un coeur de couleurs pour les six
cent mille à avoir rejoint la chaîne je
me fous pas de vous et de l'autre côté à
chaque fois vous allez voir les symboles
cercle croit vague carré étoiles qui se
reproduisent sur chacun des cartons mais
à chaque fois avec une couleur
différente et en face de chaque symbole
il y a toujours une longueur en hertz
est toujours d'une valeur différente
également pour chacun des symboles ya
pas deux fois la même valeur dans les 5
cartes en effet numéro un vous demandez
un des spectateurs de le mélanger sans
que vous puissiez voir vous à l'avance
de cette manière ce qui fait et pendant
ce temps là vous écrivez une petite
prédiction sur un bout de papier pendant
que vous écrivez votre prédiction sur un
bout de papier vous demandez également à
votre spectateurs qui
sorte soit une calculatrice soit sans
téléphone portable qui le met en
fonction calculatrice vous vous écrivez
votre prédiction là je regarde pas ce
que je fais je peux vous dire que ça va
être ma prédiction va être en tous cas
sans 97,79 une fois qu'il a finie
mélangez vous ne regardez toujours pas
ce qu'il fait vous lui demander de tenir
tous les cartons vers lui comme ça
égalisé avec le côté identique à tout le
monde vers vous et vous lui demandez sur
sa calculatrice d'additionner les
fréquences hertziennes de la manière
suivante il va sur le premier carton
prend le premier carton est noté la
fréquence du cercle
ensuite ils le passent derrière et il va
noter maintenant la fréquence de la
croix de l'autre couleur orange
ils le passent derrière il notre la
fréquence des vagues
donc là dans notre exemple c'est jaune
puis la fréquence du carré et enfin il
additionne la fréquence de l'étoile donc
vous avez bien compris
à chaque fois il doit additionner des
fréquences entre elles et en descendant
d'un cran à chaque fois donc c'est à
plus croît puisse vague puis carré puis
étoile dans l'ordre qu'il veut il
pourrait même les prendre tous les 5
devant lui et choisir un cercle une
croix un carré des vagues et une étoile
du moment en fait qu'ils ne prennent pas
deux éléments venant du même carton il a
le droit de prendre qu'un seul élément
par carton donc je trouve que le plus
simple à faire c'est com vous proposait
de lui faire égaliser de lui faire
prendre le premier puis le deuxième du
deuxième le troisième qui troisième le
quatrième du 4ème et 5ème du cinquième
il fait l'addition des cinq fréquences
hertziennes
il va trouver là en l'occurrence si vous
regardez ce que j'aime faire de la vidéo
sans 97,79 c'est une astuce
mathématiques qui se cache à l'intérieur
de ce principe qui vous fera toujours
tomber sur ce résultat là quoi qu'il
arrive si vous expliquez bien ce que la
personne en face doit faire que vous le
faites convenablement c'est à dire elle
choisit à chaque fois les cinq symboles
mais ça doit être les cinq symboles
différents et de cinq couleurs
différentes
si on fait l'addition à chaque fois des
soeurs en hertz misé dessus on obtient
toujours 190,79 sur le dos des cartons
qui sont tous identiques vous voyez que
j'ai mis mon nom j'ai mis que c'est le
cadeau pour les 600 kg appelé salt est
des 600 cas et juste en dessous vous
avez le numéro de test
je vais réussir à faire le point dessus
mais laissez le test à neuf de 7 à 9
c'est un petit moyen mnémotechnique pour
vous rappeler du résultat si jamais vous
l'avez pas fait depuis longtemps où vous
avez un doute
ça se lit un oeuf donc ça c'est le début
deux sets donc en fait faut le
comprendre 7,7 il ya deux sets et un
oeuf donc juste neuf parce qu'il ya un
seul nov
donc ça fait 1 9 2 7 qui veut dire 7 7 1
oeuf qui veut dire 9 soit 1,9 7,7 9
bah oui j'ai essayé de penser à tout et
quand même la deuxième possibilité de
présentation qui est juste l'une des
possibilités je suis persuadé que vous
êtes capable d'en trouver une encore
plus pertinente qui vous conviendra
encore mieux c'est que au lieu de
prédire vous disposez les cinq cartons
comme ça devant quelqu'un vous demandez
à une deuxième personne de sortir son
téléphone en mode calculatrice on va
dire personne numéro deux et vous
demander à la personne numéro 1 de
choisir dans sa tête pour commencer bref
voulu expliquer le principe et vous
justifiez ça comme vous voulez c'est
votre job
vous lui demandez ensuite de dire les
chiffres en hertz le plus rapidement
possible et le job du spectateur numéro
deux c'est de taper les chiffres et les
nombres en même temps que dit le
spectateur numéro un pour créer
l'addition de tout ça alors je vais vous
le dire ça va se passer tellement vives
qui va perdre pied il va pas réussir à
le faire le spectateur 2 sauf que vous
dès que le spectateur à a terminé de
prononcer sa donc il va speed et vous
annoncer tout de suite sans 97,79 et
vous aurez raison
et là vous allez pouvoir prendre le
temps avec le spectateur 1 et 2 de
vérifier et de refaire l'addition
calmement avec les calculatrices du
spectateur numéro 2 qui explique que
vous avez calculé donc très très
rapidement parce que là depuis deux
jours j'ai essayé ça sur un petit peu
tout le monde je peux vous dire cette
version est très drôle aussi quand la
personne commence à dire 40,92 plus
62,73 plus 13,02 plus 24,32 plus 56,81
et que toi tu donnes le résultat tout de
suite tu es un killer alors pour avoir
ce cadeau là que je vous fais pour vous
remercier parce que c'est bien normal
vous avez un lien dans la description
pour télécharger tous les fichiers pdf
est aussi un fichier qui reprend un
petit peu les explications a résumé de
tout ce que je viens de vous dire ce
sera quand même plus un mais quoi qu'il
arrive cette vidéo elle restera et vous
pourrez regarder si vous voulez
m'entendre expliquer maintenant pour
avoir l'une des versions collector alors
j'en ai fait trente exemplaires comme je
voulais dit au début de la vidéo
les trente exemplaires seront numérotées
celui ci étant l'exemplaire numéro zéro
donc je vous en faire gagner 30 pour ça
c'est extrêmement simple
je vais faire un tirage au sort dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo j'ai jamais
fait ça et pour le faire dans les
commentaires vous devez juste m comment
vous avez découvert ma chaîne soit
depuis combien de temps soit en quelles
circonstances si vous
en souvenez si vous en souvenez pas vous
dit pas je me suis un plus et à la fin
de votre commentaire vous mettez le
hashtag mantallot m
ent à l eau en parallèle et c'est très
important parce qu'après je serais pas
capable de vous contacter je sais pas
comment on pourrait faire donc en
parallèle une fois que vous avez fait ça
vous cliquez dans le lien de la
description ça vous envoie vers un
formulaire et dans le formulaire vous
mettez votre adresse mail comme ça si
vous gagnez je vous contacte avec ça et
votre pseudo sur youtube extrêmement
important puisque le tirage au sort va
se passer de la manière suivante le 31
août date du tirage au sort je fais donc
le tirage au sort grâce au fichier que
ça aura généré le formulaire paf je
sélectionne les 30 personnes
je regarde les pseudo je vais chercher
dans les commentaires si le pseudo a
bien laissé le commentaire avec le
hashtag je lui envoie un mail c'est peut
être toi et je te demande ton adresse
pour envoyer directement l'enveloppent
voilà tirage au sort 31 août
je pense même que je le ferai en live
sur instagram mais en fait une bonne
idée ça je ferai ça en live le 31 août
sur instagram directement en direct
comme ça vous pouvez me rajouter sur un
stade si vous le faites pas et voir le
tirage au sort directement sans coupure
sans rien comme ça vous voyez tout petit
bonus des familles on n'a jamais fait ça
sur la chaîne mais je pense que pour
fêter les 600000 cette drôle de faire si
la vidéo dépasse j'en sais rien moi les
gens c'est rien fait comme il ya trente
tours on va dire 30 me like si elle
dépasse les 30 mille like gens feraient
gagner 30 de plus c'est dire qu'au lieu
de tirer 30 personnes j'en tirerai 60 et
les tours seront numérotées de 1 à 60
voilà c'était ça la surprise pour fêter
les six cent mille personnes sur la
chaîne j'espère que ça vous plaira
que vous soyez tirés au sort ou pas
n'hésitez pas à télécharger le fichier
de manière il est là pour ça il est
accessible à tout le monde comme ça je
suis sûr et certain que les 600000 que
vous êtes vous pouvez le télécharger et
le faire n'hésitez pas à le pratiquer ne
fait pas un biais cognitif négatif par
le fait que vous connaissiez maintenant
comment ça fonctionne même si je suis
pas persuadé que spontanément vous ayez
compris mathématiquement pour que ça
marche mais ça on s'en fiche
l'important c'est ça fonctionne mais
amusez vous à le tester à le faire vous
assure que c'est très agréable à faire
et que les réactions des spectateurs en
face ou des personnes en phase soit
assez rigolote gens retournent à la
préparation des vidéos pour la rentrée
sachez que ça avance bien et qu'on va
bien se marrer à partir du 1er septembre
donc rendez vous le 1er septembre à 15
heures sur la chaîne
sauf si d'ici là on passe les 700000
mail à mon pote faut pas rêver
croyez-vous le le 1er septembre à 15
heures merci pour tout merci du fond du
coeur merci merci merci
ciao alors si c'est pas encore fait tu
peux aussi tu abonnés à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond
que tu vois voilà juste ici c'est ce
petit rond là ça marche depuis la
tablette le téléphone c'est extrêmement
pratique il n'y a plus de raison
d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool